have you ever wondered what games you
can play inside a Tesla well today I'm
going to share with you which games you
need to control for and which games you
can use your vehicle for so inside the
Tesla to get to your game section you
just tap your three little dots you come
across to Arcade and it will load all of
your games currently in the latest
version of the Tesla system we have a
number of games so we have the Battle of
polytopia which is a one person online
player game and if you go play a game
it's going to allow you to play that
without a controller next we have
Mahjong which again doesn't need a
controller Sudoku doesn't need a
controller Sky Force reloaded doesn't
need a controller Solitaire doesn't once
we get a bit further down this actual
menu of games you do need a controller
for Cat Quest you don't need a
controller for Fallout straw do you
don't blackgammon cuphead requires
controller beach buggy 2 does not
require controller chess does not
require a controller and 2048 does not
require a controller